juste un Trudeau est de retour en
personne à l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU
après quatre ans d'absence en raison
d'élection et de la covid 4 ans pendant
lesquels l'État du monde ne sait pas
amélioré le secrétaire général prévient
que de la grogne ce profil à l'horizon
quand
la crise du coût de la vie ferrage la
confiance s'effrite les inégalités
explosent pendant que la planète brûle
il dépeint un portrait sombre de la
situation la guerre en Ukraine n'est pas
la seule à blâmer c'est une cascade de
crise c'est aussi la question du covid
de l'impact et comme on dit le
secrétaire général l'impact du
changement climatique un crise globale
qui va durer pour pour l'avenir ça ne
suffit pas selon lui de décrire les
problèmes il faut trouver des solutions
c'est l'endroit où on discute et on
commence à faire des changements comment
se faire des décisions pour
retrouver la façon de répondre aux
crises Justin Trudeau montre qu'il veut
agir sur plusieurs fronts il a participé
à des sommets sur la sécurité
alimentaire et sur la lutte contre le
contenu violent en ligne puis au cœur de
Central Park il lance le compte à
rebours vers la COP15 sur la
biodiversité une conférence qui se
tiendra en décembre à Montréal le
message que le Canada compte adresser au
monde à Montréal c'est qu'on doit
accorder au dossier de la biodiversité
la même
urgence qu'à celui des changements
climatiques
la nature ne doit pas être léguée au
second plan si la ministre Mélanie jeudi
qui doit prononcer le discours devant
l'Assemblée cette année ces priorités
l'Ukraine et la lutte contre la
désinformation il va de soi que à la
désinformation particulièrement celle en
ligne affecte nos démocraties et nos
institutions démocratiques Justin
Trudeau tenait à participer à
l'ouverture de l'assemblée générale
quitte à rater la rentrée par le menteur
les problèmes discutés ici du coup de la
vie au changement climatique se
répercute aussi au pays s'ils cherchent
à se présenter comme un leader sur la
scène internationale il devra aussi
démontrer que les solutions qu'il
propose au Canadiens sont bien pensés
ici Madeleine Lemaire Radio-Canada New
York